هلا هلا هلا يالله حيو مرحبوا هلا هلا هلا
هلا يالله عيونه هلا هلا هلا هلا
ياسمين في البقاع انتشارا واسعا
صممو كاس المونديال وقعدوا على مسامع
الحاضرين اغنيه ارحبوا
لكنه خلف هذا الفيديو وقصه اطفال لا
تشبهوا القصص اللجوء
التي يصلون اليها نهايه كل اسبوع لدخول
عالم الفنون
[موسيقى]
التي قادها عبد الهادي برقصه المتناسقه
مع السعوديه
الدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
الموسيقيه واحده منها كانت اغنيه
المونديال لكن الهدف الاساسي هو شكله
المواهب التي بقيت منسيه خلف الخيام
[موسيقى]
من العامل النفسي
والانزواء وبتريح شويه الاطفال مع التعامل
والتفاعل بالاصوات والتمارين
كاس العالم التي سميت من الطين ما هي الا
نموذج من اعمال متعدده يقدمها المركز منها
دروس الرسم والطبخ التي ادخلت التفاؤل
مجددا الى قلوب اللاجئين
الاطفال
بتختفي بعد فتره لانه بيلتهب اشياء ثانيه
فاحنا يعني اقترحنا انه نحن نعمل مثل مركز
صغير نجمع هذول المواهب ونكون ونرفع من
مستوى هذه الموهبه ونتواصل مع ناس حتى مع
العالم كله انه نحن يساعدونا لحتى نحنا
هاي المواهبات تبين على الناس كلها
ايوه وللحمه البقيه
حتى ان يوتيوب منح تقديرا للصفحه التي
تنشر مقاطع هؤلاء الاطفال
فباصرارهم قدموا صوره وغيره عن الحزن الذي
عاده ما يرافق المخيمات اغنيه يتيم
العربيه البقعه